and thanks as always to the middle
option isn't too shiny for making this
evening possible and I'm absolutely
delighted to welcome our two speakers
tonight to speak on what's really
growing and I think one of the most
exciting field in the humanities right
now which is the relations between
cinema and philosophy and how cinema in
particular through the work our two
speakers have cinema new media visual
culture in general are free were forcing
philosophy to reconsider some of its
fundamental questions so the format
tonight will be so our two speakers
indeed you hang is associate professor
of philosophy you do my parents not that
West not ten he also teaches that the
economist Mendoza he's a former student
of the economic idea in the Princeton
University and he's served for a while
as
the section of the French cultural
services here in New York he's an author
of several books one of which is author
and editor of the book matrix
mathematics machine fetus if he would
came out in 2003 I guess and which was
fairly controversial but it's an
extremely smart book on the complex
commercial film making and one of the
authors he is also the editor of a
volume of the journal DT which came out
in 2005 on cinema and philosophy which
is a great great volume KT 2005
with an article by and I bet you on
and we just read an interview with our
calcium and a series of really
interesting as essays he is also
primarily but not only Burson scholars
person in cinema knows Ferguson's legacy
with cinema very well and recently
edited a critical edition of do pay a
Steven 1080 and is publishing a book on
work students to the person Einstein
controversy which is
or maybe in April our second speaker but
these many PA is a lecturer in
philosophy at the University of Essex
and has also taught me and he's also
graduated economics entire dissertation
he's the author of a number of books on
the intersection between philosophy and
social sciences he also at least also
contributed to the matrix volume and he
has just published this book which
and Foucault Ghazi did not just come up
with a bank and I also want to mention
before turning things over to books that
our two guests just published in the
collection the Batsuit which seems to be
a great collection these are two
absolutely fantastic books which I had
the great pleasure of reading one is
full hypo that coexist not dizzy manage
maybe living on the coexistence of
images in form of split screens in the
form of montage temporal disjunction and
also our existence our coexistence with
images and at Eastman key publish that
must be achieved you jab the devil's
perspective or the devil's point of view
which I just love the title and the book
as well which is a way to rethink the
relation between thought and image not
necessarily from Satan's point of view
although that comes in but also focusing
on an art installation by the two
biggest two artists who recreated the
apartment of rose
house in Rosemary's Baby and the
insulation was called Rosemary's place
and this is the starting point of an
amazing of pieces amazing reflection on
perspective
cinema
there's no culture
so welcome and
today work ok so I still say there's
been a lot of physical dresses movie
movies lately but too often I think the
other percent you relate to films just
as man illustrations of already
different philosophical ideas so we
could find in the matrix exactly Plato's
cave
all you could spike in Hitchcock
everything you always wanted to do a bad
luck off your disability check once same
well this is a bit unsatisfying to us
and in fact our question Indian dye we
share that many things would also be
some methodological approach our
question is very simple is is it
possible to better than that is defined
in films things which theory of relative
has not already offered so are true and
surprisingly yes so one way to do that
we need to start with products and
that's what the way we suggest we work
don't tell anybody but it's a delusion
its knowledge so we think that we need
to start with problems with
philosophical problems and then we think
that you can find in different practices
not philosophical practices
visual practices races problems which
are and illogical but different treaty
needs of the same problem
ok and so our question is whether if we
maintain sure the clearest attention to
the way the problem is treated for
instance in cinema we could really
berate and maybe displace the
philosophical problems which we have
okay so that's the way we work and
that's why I think we are here just make
me to give an example so more recently I
published this book which Phil mentioned
with a colleague of mine doc that were
young where we try to approach the
relation between Foucault and Sienna so
why should go well good disciple who
could enlighten us that's the great
thing with Foucault that means
absolutely no interest in see a magazine
to see literature in painting music we
had a lot various interest but cinema
was not in London in fact it was
approached by Socrates and starting from
the Kenya to see the mouth and he
replied to these people asking him
interviews it's also because you have
the impression that they have
constituents in their own field which
resonated with his own problems as a
historian and as so basically one of
these main questions was with the
possibility of having a non ideological
relation to history history is very
often in a way by which we hybrid
ideologically relates to our own self
because it's guided by the question how
did we become who we are now and
security to this question radical shift
in the approach of history that's what
he does in his philosophical and
historical practice he says that we
should do history alter to the past not
in order to have a more accurate view of
what is no more and not also in order to
explain the president but on the country
in order to get a stronger sense of the
contingency of situation so not to
explain why we have become what we are
now not to find a necessity behind all
that but on the contrary to find
a better sense of things that could be
different and that will maybe be changed
so history is full cuckoo an instrument
to stretch ourselves to alive
it's great to be married with someone
that is strange so what he meant by that
in that we wanted us to have a sense of
the contingency of what we take for
granted so all the absolute things which
we think are unavoidable should be a
convention so for instance we think that
everybody has always had a sexuality
that joint is a dimension of the human
life that or the job or someone who do
the heterosexuality would simply be to
Dallas one happy what the sexual
behaviors of the past have been and what
the perception may be about sex happy
but Foucault disapproves of these
approaches the historic society and for
me to do the literacy time to consist in
showing that the very notion of the
choice is very problem is nothing
necessary or or accident
so it's not that sexuality has changed
right it's that we must define the
sexuality by a series of changes which
constituted as a product as an object so
that means that the very notion of
sexuality must become a very so just one
possibility of something which could be
otherwise and must be defined in the
field of other things which is to see
the friction could be the Greek the
Greeks aphrodisiac or the Roman care of
the self or the Christian possible
techniques I mean these different things
was helped to relate to ourselves in a
differential way to reduce our own
present to all the differences which
they present with these other fools of
ourselves so the beauty of that is that
instead of looking at the past and the
present
the former present situation present
you know he wants to look at the present
as a cure variation something which is
already defined as a variation right so
that's that's what I'm interested in so
not to define the president as something
that changes but to define the President
as the variation in himself so very
often I think we don't we can to have a
very radical historical approach to
everything right but we usually don't
realize how thankful this that's
what emphasize now basically means that
there is nothing underneath there
changes there is nothing underneath the
changes that changes agree that what we
are what there is everyone would be
nothing but changes so the job of the
historian would be to deconstruct the
allusion of any sort of underlying
identity and to reduce everything to the
form of variation that it is the
critical work in the center which
reduces everything something else than
what it appears to be reduces everything
to think which are defined by
correlation of
there that's weird so it's a very
political relation to history in the
sense of what consciously they relate to
others in order to redefine us as others
among others as one say okay if I if
something things which don't make sense
to you right
okay now this I did decided that there
is that thing but rather that there are
changes but nothing that changes
underneath this idea actually and it's
like it's a very odd idea which goes
against our normal way of thinking so
what I'm saying here that for good
practice of history committing to a
particular philosophical conception of
the world we stopped an average but not
always doesn't feel the need to do it oh
so then this conception of the world
basically say that the world's main
defense nothing there now of course you
would probably recognize here also some
claim me but I do know that the good is
someone who try to construct clubfeet
which is based on these like
but it best but the interesting factor
is that also to lose one of his wife
felt the need to turn to cinema in order
to understand better what that is and
these are some cinnamon the general idea
is very simple safe cinema is the art of
extracting pure is best you'll be coming
from current situations to reduce
everything respected to that potential
to become strong right so that's an
interesting fact for an interesting idea
because it may mean that we can find in
the way cinema has approached historical
problems something which will indeed
resonate with fuku historical practice
there is an intention here just been
encountered
so can we learn anything about the
nature of historical events if we look
at the way cinema has approached history
but basically my general question in the
book so I'm just going to give you one
example which i think is very impressive
of the way anyone can help the three was
in concept of events which we don't find
already made in fluffy it's the example
is like and fog by
it's not my fault it's that history
sometimes very violent so why this stop
well precisely because it shares the
same concerns as concurs why because
we're settings of documentary film or
the historical events event which aims
at disturbing the relation between the
past and the present which organizes our
notion of history oddly enough in fact
maybe that's not enough state the film
is not made in order to fight against
forgetting in fact the film relates to
the past not as something which has
orchard in a different location in
denial time but on the country as
something which is an ever-present
brutality of our current situation so
basically wants to disturb the relation
between the present and the past and if
the past was just something far into and
say whenever you must relate to the past
as a virtual dimension of your own
it shows something about what you are
but as an effect also it means that our
present is nothing but precisely one
virtual possibility okay so this makes
it very clearly in an interview which he
gave to Richard Ruskin and funded so if
anyone ever that's a kuba so that's what
he says I had this idea of interrogation
question yes that's what it is
I wouldn't film which say to people not
don't forget I wasn't interested in that
but trying to understand why that
happens or rather don't wait for it to
be happens that happened in order to
care about it I coach after of well fell
out and it was the terror that it may
start the game it was indeed a huge it's
relationship question March
so in other words the point of this
historical film is not to teach us
anything about the past but rather to
make our present itself more problematic
to our own minds unsettle our relation
to ourself now so the math disturbing
are in relation to that the present
it's not a path is something which no
which can't be nerman actually so it's a
straight reversal actually if you think
about it in the notion of historical
knowledge it's so you have a very clear
example of that in the final scene maybe
if I have time actually it's true in
some of these where you have the room of
the cab I think it's a block which is
the gas chamber
and you'd say that it is a strange
observatory and in fact it means that
these images which you will see and are
not meant to be seen for themselves
they're meant to displace had in mind
the colonial war against other people
you know suspected that it was about the
caste the Soviet Union but actually
doesn't matter too much in the sense
that the point is more general than that
I think and we can still think about it
an example so the point of that we
communicate with the past not as with a
distant object but with as we the
possibility of ourselves so I think you
see how it resonates say it's a critical
relation to the present
the objective itself a defining motion
now the question is I'm just going -
Balaji and the question would be what
are the cinematic techniques that
painting uses in order to convey this
intention I know but I don't know yet
any words and can we learn anything
which may be of interest from these
techniques from the cinematic techniques
we really think that the nature of
knowledge recklessly I think there are
three major techniques or tricks in this
film which convey this sense of the
critical relationship resolution task so
the first one consists in creating the
tension between the text and images
basically the text size you cannot have
a good sense of what to share
the text reduce the images and it could
make the possibility of having a sense
of ways in the past in certain way so
instead of helping us to draw over the
Gulf of thought the film increases makes
it even harder okay there are many
things to say about this this is
properly synthetic right it's
audio-visual there is a discrepancy
there's a contradiction in what is sight
and what is chilling and this tension is
very interesting something which could
go the 17th were also very interested
aid and a fools obviously fidelity
cannot do that visual what include
traditional death well the second
technique is the juxtaposition of images
in black and white on one hand from the
archives and images in colors which are
shot and the color which is the color
instead of making these images more
realistic giving us no sense of the
reality of these games in fact makes it
even harder for us to
to represent whether it's in fact they
split the image as if we truly relate to
what they were presenting precisely
because they are uncommon there is a
beautiful mind
in the text like a heart by drunken
order we say something to say for us in
French and then I can sensation oddly
enough in tragedies thus abductor of the
bleach this is the main monastic
movement technicals
so of this brick poetry of these phantom
sleepers we can only show you the shell
and oddly enough the shadow so the color
is prostatic what separates us from the
object it's not a better representation
of the country something even move
in education in your present image of
this place which is open in the present
itself the fact that we cannot resign
with that has been the test
we are acceptable carefully we can sign
with these presents and the third
technique are these very famous
panoramic shots which in particular the
beginning and again that will point you
stream something you have the time
so good see it's a very funny scene
can we
I never be that far
very very addictive article for team
authority for damn
Mary would be busted but UDP Santa group
memory has protocols awakens wide
receivers compared to some the norm
karkos of us
just whipped up our group it's not in
canvas and others
so fueled a non-committal sorta crafty
result and he refuses to develop is not
a vegetable in Kalina in order that you
see comparative usability motocross of
us today
the come on a spree non-physical
well so I think you have so but so I'm
interested in the fact that the relation
between the past and the present here is
conveyed with these good existence it's
conveyed by a typical similar graphic
technique which is to bring in the field
that which is out of the field
so whatever what does he do it
well responds it could be a day that we
have a training model and we must
redefine the president by what surrounds
it out of its own train so the president
has been defined our series and the film
receives like that by the series of
reframing of embedded reframing by which
the identity of the present that which
we thought was just you know peaceful
landscape becomes something else
so you have missile which are constant
and which you also find in the film
which in the relation between money in
the camp and when is part of it so for
instance you from the when you are in
the cast
sighs Carol Carol
okay the village about there seems to be
just a marriage where you are in the
village cap to things which are not
compostable it cannot be possible
together our show to be coexistence by
the camera by the tracking shot so
that's the way grenade conveys a sense
of this virtual dimension so often
present do not success to one another
they could exist together in a virtual
dimension but there are possibilities so
they are just like faces of the same
thing so of course it's very worried
it's very worried because it means that
we must define ourselves by everything
we have something we must redefine
ourselves
and the interesting fact wall of blood
flow deftly shows that the meet you
or PowerPoint presentation
with
so yes but in comparison to what you've
just heard my presentation will may
sound a bit sketchy the thing that I
want to do this job of extracting rather
abrupt way underlying metaphysical
physicist which was alluding to
regarding the coexistence of the virtual
and the actual the past and the present
and do it in a way that is still in
touch with the will actual operations of
cinema in order to do this I will on the
one hand with you were a few of the
metaphysical underpinnings of delicious
and of course been relying heavily
obviously infections concepts of time
and duration and on the other hand I
would like to illustrate but in less
focused way and Patrice these views
but a series of examples taken from I
hope very diverse domains of cinema so
the first thing I want to submit is this
quote by Duluth which i think is very
interesting and quite typical of his
take on cinema the way
the relations I was a student of
philosophy extracted from an interview
that came out
published when the first volume of is to
cinema books came out says I was a
student of philosophy and although I
wasn't stupid and although it wasn't
stupid enough to want to create a
philosophy of cinema one conjunctive
conjunction made an impression of I
liked those authors who demanded that we
introduce movement to thought remember
they denounced the Hegelian dialectic an
abstract movement how could I not
discover the cinema which eternally
introduces real movement into the image
I wasn't trying to apply to the gossipy
to cinema but I went straight from the
mazda3 to cinema the reverse is also
true
one went right from cinema to philosophy
so there are really three things which
is
should emphasize here before going on
it's at first the idea that donors
doesn't think he was stupid enough as he
says to produce a philosophy of cinema
the two volumes entitled movement image
and time image are not books that we
should categorize as philosophy of
cinema the way he operates on cinema is
not by providing some kind of external
reflection on that thing because cinema
those things we call films there is no
need in fact first year along this line
of thought there's no need for
philosophy and cinema does not meet he
must be obviously but philosophy is not
even called for is not even require for
cinema to make sense to be understood
there's a lot of writings about cinema
even before any philosopher got
interested into in cinema there is there
are very intelligent discourses on
cinema problems of cinema the essence of
cinema
we lose night is not to say the truth
about what cinema is no philosophy
arsenal first thing I wanted to stress
the second night here is of course and
it's the consequence of the first
there's no need to apply philosophical
ideas to cinema later it's rather do the
as you said it's rather the opposite
move which is interesting for to learn
how not to be extract something from
cinema rather than apply resume ideas or
philosophy as we say in French pieces of
ready-made philosophy it's rather to
extract concepts from cinema in order to
do more philosophy
among different lines and finally the
idea that this operation of this
encounter is conjunction French word I
guess is a compound conjunction says in
the home port for my test unit I was
impressed by certain encounter the
encounter between cinema and philosophy
is one that doesn't need any kind of
mutation that's very important - there's
no need for kind of overlay of
theoretical ideological discourse on
cinema
philosophy to make something obscene
there is a kind of direct short-circuit
the take and actually when you read
Genesis work although it's a very
informed and he obviously has read a lot
making even more than having seen many
films he has read a lot many books many
articles on cinema critical
despite this mass of information it's
very obvious that for journalism
philosophy doesn't need much mediation
as a kind of direct tape and the wage
works for donors is as Patrice mentioned
is that well philosophers start with
their own problems and then kind of
encounter problems which are of the same
kind you have to see what that can mean
in cinema authors in cinema encounter
problems which kind of resonate with
problems that philosopher
on their own health encounter and are
trying to elaborate
so cinemas never pretext for at the
applying philosophy it's really an
extension of philosophy or a way to do
philosophy by other means and the way it
works is by extracting concepts I've
used this this expression several times
extracting concepts concepts as do those
regularly stresses is is the proper to
cannot repeat the job of philosophers
said he says to construct to produce
concepts basically that that's what
defines in a very operational way
philosophy but if cinema does not
produce concepts for its own sake and it
produces ideas there are ideas in cinema
this big cinema as the recession rather
odd way is the anima which kind of
resonate with concepts but which come
from this work of extraction there are
using cinema which which express certain
cinema trafficking problems and the Java
code
to extract the concept which adequately
which are apt to develop or unfold the
problems which these ideas cinema
graphical ideas express what concept
what problems and what ideas and also
why I mean what's the end result with
the benefits of extracting concepts in
this strange encounter in cinema
so the general question why should ever
pay attention to cinema there are other
domains
literature science there are many ways
to actually do philosophy through other
means why cinema I would say that in
fact cinema should preserve the same
benefits as any other domain in that
respect for philosophy
the idea for philosophers and especially
philosophers like de leurs or
best-selling in another way the benefit
of going through this detour is to gain
precision to reach a level of precision
that philosophy by its own means can
never reach that was a basically
Bergstrom's principle basic very
profound principle he said that
philosophy needs precision and in fact
in his view this was the main reason why
the philosopher should study science or
art or the human sciences Social
Sciences in order not so not so much in
order to understand understand what's
going on there to provide a philosophy
of this domain but in order to to attain
a level of precision level of refinement
that content and sheer concepts by
themselves can never attain so I would
say the general answer to why philosophy
is you know why what can we expect from
this encounter is more precision
we try to not to give an example of the
kind of problems ideas concepts that we
can make more precise by by assembling
or by kind of breeding in philosophy and
so I will be I won't be developing that
IG very much because it was already it
was already presented by what the nurse
has in common with person is that is
interested for reason that I don't have
time to explain he's interested in
extracting an ocean of pure mobility
notion of to be coming out of the
various forms the various happenings
that's one can witness in one's
experience is interested in on this
notion of mobility with that Mobile's
with are things actually moving here
fact of mobility issue new phenomenon
mobility and what he sees in cinema is a
direct expression of this possibility of
not only thinking but also experiencing
in a very obvious straightforward way
this pure mobility which doesn't need to
be attached to careers mobiles or things
that are actually doing the movie sheer
mobility and of course this notion of
sheer mobility is best exemplified in
the technical operation of cinema which
is the track
we had a nice example of the tracking
shot opening their opening shots of
really cool job we could illustrate the
same principle of
the tracking shot by this famous scene
from vertigo Alfred Hitchcock's movie
there's actually a little more than
tracking shots in this scene I'm sorry
for the stroboscopic effect it's
entirely due to the weakness of my
machine
the reason I'm showing this in there and
I have to come back to vertigo for
obvious reasons I have to
with relation between past and present
virtual nationals
but at their show an example traffic
shot from this movie
but there's something is stupid you
should know this here
I think Central Park well
this
the inaugural seewer
jared is supposed to meet we're going to
see Madeline
you know I hear
in this scene where they can clearly
understand that there's no way you could
have actually seen her face-to-face
their eyes do not meet again do not
cross this is the kind of metaphor for a
whole movie is a movie about lines of
actions which do not adjust we which
keep and which keep which are kept in a
kind of disjunctive state which never
quite fit together the importance of the
tracking shots as far as our question is
concerned our problem is concerned the
problem why philosophy connect with
cinema
to make its own problems we were
specific more precise this importance of
the tracking shots and there is explains
is due to the fact that in the tracking
truck we have the example of a movement
which is itself virtual there's an
actual continuous reframing that's the
principal of the tracking service
continues refraining of the scene of the
field and at the same time in most of
them most of the tracking shots there's
no way you can clearly attach the
movement this movement of the camera to
any particular mobile moving element in
the scene you could project the idea
that this virtual movement this camera
move is in fact substitute for the
subjective point of view of a particular
character here could be James Stewart
and gazing through the restaurant but in
the most general case and even here in
that same it is clear that there's no
there's no clear correspondence between
any actually moving element in the scene
and the virtual movement of the camera
so the tracking shot by itself
exemplifies the idea pure mobility
mobility has an absolute quality that
does not need any vehicle any career
so the conclusion of dealers in his
brilliant analysis of the tracking shot
is that cinema does not simply put
images into motion but and down these
images with and of self motion which is
which is if you wanted to define
characterize cinema in its essence which
is the essence of cinema is all about
and damning images with the kind of
stuff motion images as movement rather
rather than images often and of course
you know that the first volume of
further losses work on cinema is called
imagined movement image the second is
amassed on time image the tracking shot
and the long time the long take are of
course present in both volumes but you
can see how the very definition of the
tracking shots led to this inevitably to
a kind of temporal characterization of
the tracking shot rather than spatial
the tracking show
it is related to the idea of sheer
ability is already virtually something
that opens up to a purely temporal
characterization of the basic operations
of semen not only is it an example of
sort of infra or superhuman point of
view a point of view which is beyond all
views but as a virtual movement of the
camera itself it suggests something that
in fact exceeds all actual motion and
presents itself manifests itself as a
movement through time really making it
very short putting very briefly but I
think that's the the essence of the
tracking shot being itself the basic
operation of cinema more important than
framing which it has in common with
photography the essence of the tracking
shot is to extract via mobility and
project the whole cinematographic
experience into time and now of course
this suggests a problem it's a problem
that the Duluth encounters very soon in
his books and the problem is is there a
movement of the film itself the film as
such does a film
eventually reduced to a two-hour
tracking shot speaking metaphorically
because there are very few film which
actually worked this way although there
are some experiments there's lines even
Tarkovsky using very few takes very long
tails where times kind of distended to
use it dilated but most of the times
well editing comes into play and kind of
conjoins the power is of the cut with
the temporal the temporal expressive
powers of the tape but still there is
this notion this feeling that we could
on a certain level if we abstract from
the immediate the images and perception
and effects of they relate to each scene
if we kind of take some distance and
consider the experience of the film as a
whole there is a certain sense in which
you want to say that every film
basically tends to this to this idea of
one single tape one long shot which
would kind of provide the virtual
movement of the film itself which would
total eyes every moment and give provide
the essence of cinematographic all
experience how basically
generalize this problem it comes down to
the question how does the film as a home
presents itself as a single unified
experience and it's not an easy question
when you think of it it's the fact of
sitting in front of the screen for two
or three even four hours doesn't make it
a single experience by itself it's a
question we should ask does it make
sense to step out to the theater after
one hour yesterday to the pornographers
gallery where you can see the amazing
video piece back Eastern Athletic on the
clock it's a 24-hour video piece you can
see the whole film on Friday nights I
guess we spent it was really a very
fulfilling experience but of course we
were kind of frustrated too because
obviously we haven't been through the
whole experience and I think it's raised
the question what beyond the question of
narrative closure the question
of getting to the end of the story in
terms of cinematographic on experience
where does the unity of the film life
eventually we think of movies as
experiences well here they would like to
emphasize the faculty in Toulouse his
own analysis the tracking shot which was
the starting point of my presentation is
in fact well seems to be a very unstable
operation because on the one hand it's
clearly what unifies the action of the
meaning of a series of texture but at
the same time it is also what unleashes
the power is now it's a disruptive
powers that are virtually contained in
the total fuel space of the film that's
not only by some
who's to say that the tracking shot in
that respect was the negation of framing
framing provides a kind of fatality
although at least things were having
this discussion what is the best
translation
not of camera boss camera okay but still
it gives you a sense of closure but the
tracking shot being the continuous key
framing of the image is in fact
centrifugal it is a negation of framing
and it is what opens up the film the
entire film to a multiplicity of actions
that unfold simultaneously and from
which every tracking shot cuts this is
whether tracking shot does it's not only
reframing the image in real time it's
about cutting through the multiplicity
of lines of action with their own
durations and providing a sense of unity
which is at the same time totally
centrifugal and I think this is a point
which is central it's a difficulty that
there is encounters because there is a
kind of instability or tension between
or polarity between two dimensions of
cinema
and the consistency is diluted words
like systems the consistency brought
about by the tracking shot and the
notional virtual movement and at the
same time the disruptive tendency of any
tracking shot to open up the cinematic
experience to a multiplicity of
diverging iterations and this is of
course what is it's taken the most
accomplished examples of this art it's
about providing a sense of community
within the most multifarious the most
disruptive potentially disruptive
experience of a multiplicity of
iterations basically when I'm talking
about here is in fact a problem that
relates to space time and this is what I
want to get at I've mostly been framing
the problem in terms of time because I
was following the threat suggested by
backs on those extra protection of mixed
own have been following the threat of
time temporal threat but what I'm would
like to get at to get true is actually
an adequate characterization of the
cinematic problem the cinematic issue
that for philosophy in terms of
space-time space short and broad
space-time well I won't be you all know
that this is a very obvious way in which
cinema is in fact actively constructing
a new experience of space-time by merely
nearly shrinking static images two
images together the way requested the
wake chrono photography had already done
but with the parson animating mechanism
which we know that this
is in fact in itself a kind of
modernization of space-time you may know
that Death Zone who is not very fond of
cinema although he went to the movies
but I don't think there is enough to
write a whole book about the movies he
seemed very fertile Bergson used as you
may know to say that well this kingdom a
terrific this kinematically rendering of
space-time of spatial temporal
experience is in fact an adequate model
for the general illusions of
intelligence the way we cut things down
to static images in order to animate
them using relying on some kind of
abstract power of animation some kind of
abstract movements and eventually a
homogeneous timeline which would be the
kind of serial the serial scheme of
things the way things succeed each other
chronologically this for him was the
kind of spatial temporal model that
intelligence resorts to when it wants to
come to terms of becoming and for him
he'd have of course that you know very
negative ring to it because the idea was
that not only this illusion could be
overcome and it should be overcome in
order to to for philosophy to actually
sold its own problems well what I would
like to suggest non relying on a few
example providing your example is that
this notion of space-time could be
reevaluated in a more positive sense and
maybe in a sense which dollars while
sometimes defining things in terms of
block disgusto space-time blocks and was
kind of wary about the direction of talk
that kind of cuts across the Burke
Sounion the persona privilege of time
over space and in a way would like to
provide the positive a positive version
of the circles spatial organization of
time which person announcer
and this can be understood in two ways
and it's really two very different kind
of example I would like to introduce on
the one hand you could view the matter
in a in an intensive way stressing the
temporal the world temporal and spatial
temporal space-time and the other way
would be symmetrically to emphasize the
spatial component based on extensive
approach on the one hand and this is
vertical which will be helpful here you
could kind of try and see how the
construction of a time image which is
ultimately what every film is getting as
according to Duluth the virtual tendency
of anything is to
read some kind the equivalent of the
time image it's not something that is
reserved for certain themes or a certain
period of cinema should we do this
closely there's no clear-cut opposition
between one kind of cinema and the other
it's a rather question of tendencies as
a way so this is the first line of
examples particular was the example of
an intensive take on spatial temporal
experience and on the other hand will
rely on a very different example which
is a series 24 which is a very nice
example of the way cinema or television
but at this point the limits between the
two and not very interesting
the way cinema or television that
actively produces a new kind of space
time in which the tiny Minister diligent
argument develops according to new
dimensions can you unfold it among new
dimensions so very quickly and it's just
another way of putting it so I will be
to Norman this the problem space time is
basically a problem of coexistence the
word with introduced at least the
coexistence of the past in the present
as a way to go beyond the merely
chronological serial linear conception
of time the succession moments phases
coexistence introduces the complementary
complementary idea of things actually
unfolding through time by coexisting and
again this can have two meaning for
existence and be further as the
coexistence of past and present the fact
that the present does not succeed the
past but kind of carries the past along
with it or it can be understood
extensively the coexistence of duration
spread out in space the question of how
different lines of actions lines of
duration can be part of a single whole a
single experience but the two aspects
are really I think essential components
of this cinematic experience there are
two problems that we have to solve as
philosophers because they touch on the
most I would say the most basic concepts
that we need in order to understand the
way things hang together and the most
general sense of the term a lack of
definition provided by an analytic
philosopher called
feel fruit sellers used to say that
philosophy is really
I would say metaphysics is really about
understanding how things in the most
general sense of the term hang together
in the most general sense of the term
coexistence is one word that has been
running through the history of
philosophy in Latin
sometimes with Nexus Nexus is a word
which has been running through this
short history of philosophy to capture
this problem of how things hang together
in space and time
okay there is in the same interview said
the following
no wait sums up everything I've said so
far it seems obvious to me that the
image is not in the present but the
image represents is in the present but
not the image itself the image itself is
a misshapen in the sample of time from
the present which merely flows either as
a common inaudible
or at the smallest divisor relations of
time are never seen in ordinary person
that they are seen in the image as long
as it's in the creative one in its
renders time relations relations that
can't be reduced to the present sensible
and miserable for example an image shows
a man walking alone along a riverbank in
a mountain region in this image there
are at least three coexistence durations
three rhythms the relation of time is
the coexistence of durations in the
image which has nothing to do with the
present that is what the image
represents the concept of the image in
the president's only applies to mediocre
or commercial images I think this kind
of sums up the two books regulars
eventually very it's a very simple
problem understanding that what is it
important about cinema is not the
feeling of the present what is presented
to you because the image which is
ultimately essential
never present never given in the present
it may represent things happening now
but this is really a pretext what makes
a film what makes the movie the movie is
the way the images are presented to you
in a very odd way in the sense that
they're never actually only present but
always presented to you at the same time
has passed
or maybe as future to be the image is
the Nexus of time relations in the way
that it describes things using this very
simple example which is evolution to
famous Australian example involving
birds and a river exactly the same
problem very simple example shows that
it is at the same time question of space
enough time the question of space and
time because the problem ultimately is
about the coexistence of durations
rhythms not
you're conscious but also in the world
which the image represents in the space
which the film constructs as you know
and refer to this earlier going to do
Lizzie's own orientation ethical
orientation is Burke's alien origins you
might say his analysis converges towards
this notion of the time image which is
the modality regime of the cinematic
image which captures sentence taken from
first a little time in its pure state
put it on I'll eat a tree so there are
many examples of this but the most
striking those which are the purest
example introduces you are examples of
radicals image crystal crystal images so
why a crystal and how weather the
criteria to identify crystal image
well there are no criteria that's an
interesting fact there is no way you can
actually point at an image in a film and
say oh there it is I have this image
crystal which actually captures a little
time in its purest state
that is that the image which would
present itself as this sheer Nexus of
time or space time relations without
ever without a recrystallization or
reducing to an actual state or an actual
mental state given to the consciousness
of the spectator there's no way you can
identify certain images as Christian
images as opposed to other images which
would not be crystallized or lacking
something essential you might say having
a residue is that this is not really
true because he gives examples but the
point is these examples are very
troubling the thing to have to
understand is that there's a scheme and
kind of philosophical scheme behind his
definition of the crystal image
it's explicit I'm not guessing here
there is is very easy to about the fact
that the philosophical scheme of this
concept of Christian religion is taken
from Mexico reproducing mind energy
volume is translated as mind energy
respect some describe to pathological
cases of Paramecium the feeling of TV
which is sometimes can become very very
intrusive and quite pathological instead
with certain persons having kind of
constant feeling of misery which and
Strange's them radically from experience
in their relation how does it work well
what is environment I'm not gonna
explain what is it's taking person but
the essential point here is that in the
feeling of deja vu the way Braxton
interprets it you have a kind of super
impression overlay of the present the
actual presence image you get by simply
perceiving things and the memory of this
present not the memory
the memory that will be brought back by
this perception and memory from
something that happened to you in the
past no the memory of this present that
you're actually experiencing which is
kind of given simultaneously with the
actual perception so the interpretation
of the souvenir depends on the dish of
you the Paramecium according to Bergson
the right interpretation is to
understand that here we have an instance
of the coexistence of the presence of
the actual perception and the immediate
memory of this perception so that the
perception is actually present itself in
this kind of spectral eerie dimension of
being at once the present that it is and
the past that it already is - the past
it's an instance where the past is very
very course elusive but in most cases
but it's an instance of the past
coexisting in a very literal way with
the present the password is simply a
dimension
experience it's not something that
happened to you before it's what's
happening now in the direction of the
past because the past is not again is
not a dimension that it's not an archive
of whatever happened it's not the
affirmation of past present the past is
actively present as coexistent dimension
of experience which relates to what as
we say more mental or normative physical
level so what does there is extract from
this it's a double operation of
extraction he has to extract something
from production on the one hand and
extract something from cinema from
Burton extracts the mere idea the
coexistence or super impression of the
virtual past and the virtual memory of
the present and the actual perception of
the present the coexistence of virtual
and actual past and present memory and
perception but they are given in a state
of coalescence or fusion fusion and this
is what he needs
what do this needs to understand the
fundamental operation of cinema the fact
that the virtual movement of the camera
the image as a temporal as a movement
through time even as a movement through
time
in fact constantly aims at providing
this kind of experience although it
doesn't always reach that goal it's
always aimed at provide
the next day is where the actual and
virtual are so doing fused together and
giving in one single experience the
present being at once something that you
can understand that perspective of the
past or the present being also in itself
the reminiscence of something that has
not yet happened so the examples because
that was my study
how can we identify such moments such
crystal images you understand the
metaphor of the crystal and I didn't
read that the the metaphor because it's
a metaphor the crystal comes from the
fact that a crystal actually
presents itself as a very translucent
piece piece of matter which which kind
of
which displays the virtual image of
certain circumstances life is right
presidents of virtual images next times
of when sometimes referred to as total
refraction a virtual image that is seems
to be floating in the middle of the of
the crystal and which is kind of
contemporary with the actual reflection
of the environment on it's a different
size the image in de luces the way that
it is using it is reduces to the notion
of the two-faced two-sided image one
side is in the virtual the other side is
in the actual one side is actually
perceived the other is given in the
element of pure past few remember this
is what is crystal knowledge examples he
gives because it gives examples are very
Australia are very I would say
disturbing unsettling he refers in many
places too
see which invokes Mirror Mirror why
don't you try George was supposed to
think you're lost but he lost a sore
head and shot room
and you are ingesting
he had Disha everybody we can get into
the sunrise
you me who you crispy and one for
harvested nature keeps his original
nature in the end
at hand you hurt yourself as eautiful
No
I knew I'd find you two together if I
haven't Elsa you didn't know that
your silent friend will get the play you
will be free to spend my money well you
weren't the only one who wants me to die
good friend the District Attorney is
just itching to oh I'll stop here you
then do some acts of breaking glass and
shattered mirrors the only point I want
to stress is that it seems to me the
reason why the vs. uses this example or
refers to this film the main reason is
that mirrors are obviously involved and
that there is a very clear visual
instance of laminated field of view the
images Frank and
multiple-- reframed by all these mirrors
seems to give a literal literal
it may be too literal are any scenes of
this kind crystal image images is it
enough to have mirror reflections and
this kind of many at least effects to
have a crystal image probably not
and as a matter of fact the Rose does
not really elaborate on this example who
is it repeatedly let's never make
something really interesting and RNA is
another of his examples here again you
have mirrors and long tails and several
operations which kind of suggests the
stratified nature of the space-time time
this is what the deuce has to say when
they suddenly one of the offers for whom
damage is released in the president
because demons release films offering
this depends
Junkers depend entirely on the
coexistence of it origines durations
okay let's assume is in the complete
statement and finally another example
that I found in do this is of course a
mistake it's not very good but late
spring this according according to to do
this may be the first historically the
first time in it first pure time images
vt basis but it's definitely also an
image that comes when we first that
comes with DVD when refers to the
crystal
the woman laid aside her father it's
going to be married through the clutch
it's important because it's also a
matter
collecting memories from the mother is
not there anymore and the nostalgia
occurs relates well as important is this
scene which the were described as still
life still not is an instance of crystal
image and why is that
why well there is never said one never
sees one there is a stream this display
of shadows and kind of floating quality
the image but again why is this image
this particular image particularly
exemplifying the coalescence fusion of
the virtual and the actual in what sense
is this image is not given in the
present as in mediocre or commercial
it's not very clear okay and the only
way is by follow us here to actually
provide criteria rigorous application of
the concept is to rely on the clot on
the fable the narrative structure with
you
it's because this film is about memory
pocket about memory and that we know
things about the characters involved in
this particular scene that we can
interpret this image as one instance of
crystal image so my suggestion is this
at this point if we don't want to over
to or the examples of dualism enter in
some kind of a game which is consistent
in
interpreting the very film's the very
example provided by donors and long
division lines which is not very
interesting yes I think we should come
up with new examples where the crystal
quality the crystalline quality of the
image is not very obvious and where we
kind of find eminent criterion for
applying the concept by eminent
criterion I mean criteria which not
solely rely on the fable on the
narrative structure the psychological
patterns which we tend to identify with
the characters eminent eminent elements
which have to do on the contrary with
the space-time structure of the film
itself and here I come back to very good
and simply to say that the whole film is
structured and I think we reflect back
on the example that just given this is
the way we should approach the problem
of the time image not by analyzing a
single tank or a single scene but by
understanding the structure of the whole
brings us back to the problem of the
unity of skill experience the whole
field where you go is about the overlay
or super aggression of this woman and
this woman Madeline and jelly same
access Kim Novak and bobbing two very
different characters they're absolutely
the opposites in every regard and of
course this is very troubling instance
of these act for James Stewart at least
and for this picture certainly because
what happens at the last third of the
field not really the last heart is that
this the first character man which was
already a fiction role played by this
woman this is at least what we get from
the
narrative this this woman who replaces
the this bathroom is utterly
unbelievable and James Stewart's I she
is a fraud and at the same time she is
kind of a living testimony of the fact
that this woman has never died it's a
very complex plots and a rather untangle
experience for the spectator himself
because looking at this woman cannot
stop thinking about the other woman and
sees her trace behind the kind of
calming makeup yeah cinematic is I agree
which is really sustained until the
sorry when you when you think of it this
is quite rare to have this name a
feeling that this woman here which we
know is is the real one is cannot be
believed
as a character even as a movie character
she's actually unbelievable and this is
what the film is about in this scene
very thing the scene where James Watt
asked Jenny the second woman dress up
like Madeline into kind of and buddy her
plastic qualities what happened is very
interesting because we have in a way
they're going to do something very
reprehensible last four were at the
scene so you can get a sense of what
happens when she comes out of the
bathroom we just asked her to put her
hair right
sorry she had to die and the Burman was
the missing element he asked her to fix
that and when she is done this is what
you get
which I guess is goodbye five
and crystal image in the most obvious
literal sense
resurrection
baahir journey
or at sea quality of image of course
itself she's a crystal
she's all that in the same time but
my point is des
of course
it would be a rather trivial way of
identifying the crystal image of
replying division concept to movie to
simply
to see me
sorry I simply identify the fantastic
quality of the image that we play with
colors and filters and so on there must
be something else something deeper going
on and in order to understand this is
something I have I have been explaining
quite extensively in my book you have to
understand that space is involved the
space not only the narrative structure
but the actual space time of the movie
itself is involved in the process of
identifying crystal images so there are
IQs like junkets even when Madeline
herself is presented this is these are
two images taken from the scene we've
seen few minutes ago the scene in the
Ernie's restaurant there is a very
strange entrance where this image is
succeeded by this one
well it's not a very very clear this is
clearly a difference
providing the overall expression maybe
even in the makeup I don't know and this
kind of substitution seven chakras are
first cues that enable the spectator to
understand that there's something going
on which is which has to do with the way
things connect in this very serious
spatial temporal frame of San Francisco
and Francisco never seen it before the
conclusion I've reached by simply
reflecting on the the opening scene
credits
very nice the graphic animation by Elvis
is that the overall structure in your
spatial structure of the movie is akin
to the district that is the
non-orientable space the one sided
surface which has the property of
inverting the elements that across the
space slide along one of the sides in
fact is only one side it's like a no the
one style of this twisted silencer or a
twisted strip you end up reversed and
I'm really trying to salvage by using L
and sliding it you'll see why come back
inverted I think the the overall
structure of the space-time is that of a
non-orientable space that the non
chronological time
which relates to what I've been saying
that desire you cannot be fully
understood if you don't if you don't
take into account the non-orientable
quality of the space itself of course
you could also you could also understand
this by merely observing this very
strange curves that are that James
Stewart is tracing in San Francisco by
chasing this woman it's kind of Forex
quality which ultimately leads to the
conclusion that there's no way you can
orient yourself in the space anyway my
point is that you cannot realize merely
on images even on takes in order to
identify identify the spatial temporal
structure of film and and the nature of
the crystal image crystal images as the
root himself says it's a germs it's a
differential element which is already
present in any image this relates to the
idea that the time image is not
particular kind of image is not a
category it's a tendency which run
through the whole history of cinema
and which is already virtually present
in every movement the upshot is that
there's no way you can pinpoint
particularly meant to say there you go
there it is I could say the four texts
which suggest something that is akin to
the vortex of time and you do that
eventually you end up playing with
metaphors so for example I think one
something that is more telling more
interesting is reflect on reverse donny
schatz the tracking very interesting
tracking shot which combines the
wandering tracking shot camera being
tracked and the optical ways of the
article zooming the article
Azumi resumed at the same time you have
virtual movement virtual camera movement
and this feeling of space and distorting
itself which is a nice illustration nice
an exemplification of the spatial
temporal ultimately spatial temporal
issue and yes well I won't really
develop this example which I hadn't
managed an exam for the second
orientation which I think will be
required in order to
there which is to take into account the
the other problem the other issue of the
coexistence of duration in space not the
coexistence of several layers of of time
within a single direction whether the
duration of a particular scene or the
duration of the film itself of the
duration the subjective duration of the
spectators consciousness but the actual
distribution of several durations or
lines of actions in humans in a single
scene or even single moon there's this
genre cinematic Jean which has something
times we call urban Symphony the
cross-section fills into the stranger
but originally Symphony overstock on
Berlin or you could even think about
symantec the example most recent example
in my view losing belong also
multi-screen multi-screen seems like
this one is 24
like to say only one thing that of
course this is the typical action movie
it's probably an instance of the media
or commercial feel that's to lose that
in mind in in a sense but in another
sense it's a very remarkable
illustration of how a song which is
entirely devoted to providing effects
such as the cliffhanger or effects very
intense suspense sustained for hours
literally 24 hours how a jar which is so
clearly devoted to the most
sensory-motor quality of cinema to use
to lose its expression how is the movie
of this genre Susan this Jean can
actually produce a space-time experience
which
I think I would even say early called a
nickel track which is the experience of
a single hole of the world highly
connected most notably by the devices
which help the protagonist to
communicate at a distance using GPS cell
phones and all kinds of tracking devices
but which at the same time is totally
disruptive wait and false is really
parallel lines of patience parallel
directions or local times which
crisscross which get synchronized but
which provide an experience acting
experience of a totality which is
constantly fragmenting itself so the
imploded world unemployed involve the
catastrophe has already taken place as
you know it's really the post-september
11th movie the catastrophe has already
taken place the world is fragmented and
what you get is a kind of splintered
laminators pay time with things hang
together quite loosely disconnected and
reconnecting themselves in real time but
of course the whole point of the series
as explaining in chapter of my book
flakka a real time which in fact is a
total fiction which doesn't work as we
think sure because there's no action at
a distance
despite all the nice technologies we
have to synchronize durations principle
of the series is one of an active
disruption of durations or disconnection
that's nevertheless kind of hang
together in a fractional multiverse the
blinking fragmented world which is
probably
I thank you for your time
okay so we have a few minutes for
questions
so they would like to start
so the maybe maybe I can ask you if if
you would come back to the question of
the plot and of narration because you
mentioned both of your examples and both
your talks the point was to extract
something that wasn't necessary to
cooperate applied by plot but not to
make narrative the most significant part
so and not to make it certainly not
makes the unity but what I think the way
it hangs together
one good thing can one do a really a
target with narratives and can one do a
way to tell you with the fable or isn't
I mean in order for me to check the
strength of Jack all scales argument is
that it's precisely in these moments of
tension between plot and
of time pure aesthetics that something
happens you see that or you I mean you
both go more towards that's what it
seems to me in this chronology is really
trying to get away from the movement
image from pot and to locate in modern
sin post-war said something that's not
promise not to hurry
as a matter of fact
he's not interested
even very fun
whichever say so he sees the microphone
is not because it is true that is you're
only relying on the job if you will be
taken
and we how can you use the cinematic
medium itself
Oh
the interest
so now what concierge says is slightly
Lincoln because he says that basically
your bruises to the distinction between
classical female and mother
gives me the time and then the time
image and so what you want to say that
the well we have never delivered is
nothing
once said we is a kind of culture
movement within the movement which
and that will cure girl I think of
himself in gaining the case Authority
say
let's take the all set examples races
because they weren't interested in and
easy to see these movements in which the
image is not functional winter shot
without toys and there is a relation so
if it's a free movement so he is the one
who's interested in these movements wish
when his case
but if it's not the many moments which
are temple
have a movement which are functional in
denarii
but on the net
which is a very strong sense of time
which is different from following
different stations and story so that the
case is about anything the problem is
not whether it's about a new metal but
how do you relate to the event and to
relate to it in an area where we mean
but that's a definition maybe that's not
true but we mean simply to go through
the different stages of the action one
after the other so what do this day be
well there is another word related to
event which describe the temple
succession of the community interest
where the roses that were seen in that
first moment you think and the question
is whether what I mean we probably that
to be an interesting discussion to
happen we can probably say that the
definition of narration
one station had a dual succession that
may be wrong with this generation
the very fact that donors cannot
pinpoint the Christian image with us
implicitly or explicitly relying on the
plot Marcis are the contradictions